à l'époque, je pensais que je prenais la
bonne décision maintenant, je ne connais tout simplement pas
Vega enfer d'un bamf un fils c'est le
genre de leadership que j'attendrais d'un
vétéran tu dois être prêt à tout
ce que tu penses que j'ai honte de  montrez du respect
pour quelqu'un qui a sauvé des milliards de vies,
les bâtards assiègent actuellement
notre colonie sur des essaims de premier choix
là-haut vous avez déjà vu ces choses
avant qu'aucune colonie entière ne
disparaisse du jour au lendemain Je pensais que c'était
juste une rumeur idiote
Je me souviens de Hugh le  L'alliance enterrée vous a
battu le sang a frappé leur bataille en vous
masturbant Je sais à quel point vous essayez de
protéger tout le monde parfois les circonstances
rendent cela impossible ce que je vois ici est
une escouade des forces spéciales hautement qualifiées
vous n'êtes pas des gardiens aujourd'hui nous découvrons de
quoi vous êtes fait  club marin c'est l'
heure de bruler que
tu penses que j'ai fait la voûte